the 63 previous recipients of the Oscar
for Best Foreign Language Film come from
nations that span the globe
from Asia to Africa Europe to South
America
this year's nominees are equally diverse
representing countries from three
different continents regardless of their
nation of origin their universal themes
transcend all boundaries by touching our
common humanity here are the nominees
for Best Foreign Language Film from
Austria amor
directed by mikhail Honaker from norway
kontiki directed by Jochen rooney and
Espen Sandberg from Chile No directed by
Pablo Lara from Denmark a royal affair
directed by Nikolai or sell from Canada
Warwick directed by kim yu-na
and the Oscar goes to a more Austria
thank you very much for this honor I
have to sing Michael Parker Don Berna
from Sony classics
thank you very much thank you to my
producers they are here all market many
goes me here cuts feathers cash
different on thank you to my great crew
thank you to my wife she was member of
the crew she's supporting me since 30
years you are the center of my life and
thank you above all to my both main
actors a man will Viva ash only 20 neon
because without them I will not stay
here thank you